china's economy beat most expert
forecasts and expanded by 4.8 in the
first three months of 2022.
strong manufacturing activity and a
boost in infrastructure spending early
in the year drove much of that growth
but major challenges threaten the
outlook of the world's second largest
economy
the global situation has been complex
and fluid domestically covered 19
continues to have an impact that's why
some major indicators slow down and
there's a pressure on economic
performance
china is battling its worst coronavirus
outbreak since the beginning of the
pandemic and tens of millions of people
nationwide have been confined to their
homes
lockdowns imposed in march across major
industrial and commercial hubs including
shanghai and shenzhen have crippled
supply chains and assembly lines
analysts say the damage caused by
shutdowns will be further felt in future
economic data
but retail spending has already
contracted by 3.5 percent unemployment
has also risen foreign business leaders
say beijing's zero tolerance approach to
krover 19 is harming both the domestic
and global economy the west and and
japan korea all the big economies have
strong interest that china changes tune
because
thirty percent of all goods in china
manufacture goods have some sort of
china in there so if china actually
sneezes you know the world catches a
cold we need china to succeed we need
china to open up in order to actually
maintain also the global economy at a
certain speed
speed and the global economy needs china
now to succeed because we have a war in
ukraine which has a ripple on effect and
this is like a perfect storm coming out
together unfortunately
rising inflation and a cash crunch in
the property sector are also dragging on
growth the government has set a gdp
target of around 5.5 percent this year
it's the lowest in decades but many
believe this figure will be tough to
achieve without the rolling out of more
aggressive stimulus measures
still china's leaders insist on
maintaining the most heavy-handed
pandemic measures in the world
the cities of xi'an suzhou and jungjo
have joined shanghai in imposing
restrictions following local outbreaks
over the weekend
katrina yu al jazeera beijing